welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul AKA Deadpool and this
video we're breaking down Deadpool 3
with a strikes over the movie's back in
production and we have a brand new look
at the film thanks to the people at the
mirror the newspaper's been given
several exclusive images and a whole
host of new information that we're going
to be breaking down now technically
technically a if if the studio is
involved in letting this stuff get out
of the papers to cover it then it's not
really a leak but I am giving a heavy
spoilers warning I'm nice like that I
think this stuff will spoil what's two
pretty cool cameos in the film so if you
don't want to know then please turn off
now look I'm begging you to do it mate
either way I feel we're heading to a no
way home situation where you can
probably find out everything about the
movie before it releases so don't make
me tap the channel name don't make me
tap it anyway without the way huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
Deadpool
[Music]
tree okay so I feel like the movie is
pretty much going to become Deadpool
kills the fox Universe in case you
aren't up to speed with the comics this
is actually a long running thing that
they've done thematically with a
character in sort of what if stories
there's been loads of them like Deadpool
kills the Marvel Universe Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe again and now I
think they're doing it with a fox
franchise this has been shown in some of
the set images which show the 20th
Century Fox logo in what looked like it
might have been the void both Wolverine
and Deadpool were down there too and
we've seen some shots from the mirror
confirming a new character that is
sabertooth in his classic first X-Men
look we can see him going toe-to-toe
with Wolverine and we already know
what's going to happen to the character
at some point Deadpool carries around
his head and and therefore Tiny Tim he
won he won't be coming home this
Christmas a Daniel rpk posted to his
patreon last night that leev shriber
will once more be returning for this
movie he played saber-tooth in X-Men
Origins and many think that this might
be who's behind the costume here
personally I actually think this will
will be the original and that Tyler M he
he will end up returning that
decapitated headmate look look there
looks a bit like Tyler does in 2023 and
I think it would be really cool to
actually get that actor back kind of
feel like leev might be playing a
variant of saber-tooth at some point in
the film and that he might appear in his
look from that movie instead of him
being here alongside Sabertooth the
miror also posted toad will be returning
too but we'll have to see if Ray Parks
is in the role man got in a bit of a bit
of trouble a couple years back so I
don't know if if Disney are going to
want to have him involved and and that's
kind of also why maybe Darth Maul hasn't
been popping up in Star Wars after solo
now I think there's Absolut lots of
timeline stuff you know what it's all
over the place of chronology but you
know you know what I'm trying to say
either way toad will be appearing in the
movie and I think there's no way that
Deadpool doesn't ask if he knows what
happens to a toad when it's struck by
lightning I can definitely see that
being the kind of joke that Deadpool
does and if if he's killing the fox
franchise he might as well kill that too
either way these characters both
featured in the first X-Men film and I
can see them showing up here together in
this Wasteland this Wasteland might even
be all that's left to Fox after Disney
got s purchased the studio and put it
under their umbrella it's now known as
20th century pictures and this movie
might even be about Deadpool killing the
fox now you have to be careful with what
we're showing because even though this
is all public we had some on
the last video the guy took the photos
and videos he actually sent out
copyright strikes to me den and nerds
and everything always even though we
were just talking about the report I
know rine from screen Crush got hit up
with one as well and the photographer
was asking for money to let the strikes
go very very shady stuff um but
thankfully for me and Josh YouTube
stepped in but yeah it's a bad practice
to go around claiming this stuff that's
clearly been used in a fair use Mana
either way I'm going to avoid using as
much of this as I can but it seems like
it's going to be a pretty big scene in
the fight I'm guessing that Wolverine's
brawling with them and then Deadpool
comes in and it's off with his head man
is just providing it around like some
classic Deadpool and I think it's
going to be a pretty funny scene on top
of this we also have somewhat
confirmation of two actors that are
returning to the Marvel Universe first
though mate quick plug if you enjoy
these videos then please click the join
button and become a channel member
you'll get early access to breakdowns
like this every week and you can sign up
for just 99 cents a month to get all our
early content right now we've got a
50-minute audio version of our
Apocalypse Now analysis and yeah huge
thank you for all you guys support
anyway it's been long rumor that
Jennifer Garner is coming back and she's
going to be playing Electra in the film
she actually spoke with kider earlier in
the week and had this to say when she
was asked about it question for you did
you ever think you were going to wear
the Electra suit again I don't know what
you're talking
about so what could you mean I'm
hypothetically thinking you could be in
a Deadpool sequel hypothetically not
that I'm aware of okay I'll avoid Ive
not going to be winning the Oscar
anytime soon are you Jennifer are you we
that acting and I feel like we're going
to see their franchises coming back was
the thought Ben Affleck might be back as
Daredevil as well but so far we haven't
really had anything that shows it either
way the rumors around him kind of go
back and forth but if Electra is back
then who knows man did meet Jennifer
when he was playing the role and the
pair then went on to get married can see
how that might be awkward with him now
being married to Jennifer Lopez and in
the end maybe Jenny's getting blocked
hey set all that up for one absolutely
joke you should
unsubscribe now on top of this moving
over to Secret Wars we also had Patrick
Stewart talking about things involving
the movie he doesn't necessarily confirm
he's in it but yeah watch the interview
and make up your own mind I love that
you had a chance to bring your character
Professor X back into Doctor Strange
we've seen some X-Men also come into the
Marvel family there's rumors that we may
see you in the Avengers Secret Wars do
you want to put that rumor to rest right
now um I I I cannot put it to rest
because it's not a fact either for or
against it it is a possibility Hugh
Jackman and I looked upon Logan as being
our
farewell uh given that I died in that
film although a mul I've been told I've
actually died several times already
right he just keeps coming back
folks how do I do it but so there's a
possibility and that's all we need
that's all we need that is enough for us
to get excited know that and uh you
could get lucky also I love how these
actors just kind of have to dance around
the questions cuz fy's got that sniper
rifle aimed at them all time it's like a
bit Unbreaking bad and man could hit the
Thumbs Up Button from a mile away but
you're going to need Professor X's
powers to try and get a confirmed answer
now Stuart is 83 at the moment so they
might be in a squeeze for the stuff
constantly getting delayed I think that
they should probably film like yesterday
like film yesterday mate or or the
second walren gets a script done just
just get it bloody shot there's been
rumors that Ian McKellen's in it too and
I feel the pair will both beat you in
Deadpool 3 as well Magneto he's still
got that swag need out and he's one of
the best comic book villains of all time
who'd be such a cool person to have in
the MCU I think Deadpool dealing with
them all such a good way to take things
and it's kind of bringing things full
circle from his Trilogy too though he's
existed in the fox X-Men Universe he's
never really felt like he's part of
their films even with the odd Cameo here
and there still though we had a
different Colossus different Juggernaut
and it felt like he was just sort
of loosely connected but you'd never say
it's all connected now because of this
it kind of brings that together too and
builds off something that people have
wanted to see for a long time Deadpool
kills is such a big staple of the comics
and to actually have an opportunity
where Deadpool can kill loads of
characters from a franchise just seems
like a home run so I'm guessing that
it's all going to go down and I'm
actually really curious to hear what
your thoughts on leaks like this are I'm
guessing that if you up to this point of
the video that you might be cool with
him but do you think all this stuff
coming out before a film actually hurts
it in the long run I know with no way
home that it helped to build a Hy but
would you guys like to go back to a time
where we didn't know anything and
actually had some surprises hey and it's
a spoiler man asking you that so you
know we're getting to the point where
it's a big question either way comment
below and let me know and huge thank you
for sitting to this point in the video
you want to get some heavy spoilers
merch we've also got our t-shirt line
located below the video that will let
you pick up all kinds of tops like our
Theory time on House of dragon stuff
Marvel teas and a lot more you drop new
designs on there all the time too so
keep an eye out and thanks for all your
support if you want something else to
watch we've got some breakdowns on
screen right now going over all those
trailers that released over the weekend
Godzilla X Kong I think it's Godzilla
and Kong House of Dragon season 2 The
Boys season 4 trailer they're all on the
channel now so if you want to see more
breakdowns and head up over to them
without the way huge thank you for sing
through the video I've been your host
Paul and I'll see you next time take
care peace